okay hi everyone we are talking about a
wolf language design issue to do with
making rafts as we call them to be
connected to entities
so let's take a look at a basic case
here
okay we have an entity blob for London
and so essentially as soon as you type
the Open Bracket this this interface
comes up so the template box and there's
an attached cell there
um and it's been populated with you know
all the things you could query here so
for example there's just information
about The Entity such as property count
data set of properties Etc and then
there are the properties themselves
um
okay
um okay
all right
um
gone I mean how
how are we sorting these properties for
example
um this is really stupid sorting so I
mean but didn't we have to solve that
problem Alan for documentation
is Alan here yes if you're muted Alan if
you're if you're replying
foreign could somebody ping Allen maybe
he's a
oh he says he's having an audio issue
yeah okay all right
okay
uh so yeah and you know if you just
wanted to remove this interface
um then you could type backspace
um or so sorry you could type Escape we
should get rid of it or um in an empty
field you could type backspace and then
it sort of selects the entire template
blob and dismisses the attached cell and
then you can just delete it
um to get it back again
if you put the insertion appointments in
the brackets you get that little you
know if you click on that little
magnifying raft then you'd get the
interface
um and if you hover over the brackets
you'd get the same thing
um I think that there are a few kind of
quirks and questions I've put throughout
here I think it probably makes sense to
Circle back to those at the end okay um
yeah
all right so the thing I'm
okay
um okay so yeah the idea is that
obviously in this state uh there's no
filtering going on
um and you can just scroll down that you
know list of of properties if you just
kind of want to see what's there and
explore it and you know sort of see what
things there are for cities for example
um the one of the things we talked about
previously was making sure that people
knew this was a
um I'm gonna say at the moment natural
language-esque search
um I'll explain that a bit later but in
other words it's not just kind of string
matching so um that's why I've uh kind
of italicized those those properties at
the top because you know property count
is really just referring to the string
you know property counter et cetera
whereas the properties themselves
actually have common names as well as
the clinical ones okay by the way
nursing property values sounds like a
lost and found
um I mean it it should say
those are
probably is not
properties missing for this entity
or something
sure okay yeah I I should say that
there's also um I mean you know again we
talked about this specifically you know
previously including the list of of
missing property values there
um but there people have brought up kind
of like you know very significant
concerns about whether that can actually
be implemented again it might be best to
Circle back to that well I don't know
well I understand in what sense what
well the what can be implemented
whether we can know which property
values are missing in this way
but I thought we went through this side
we talked about the engineering of this
we simply have a vector one of the
properties of this entity is which
properties are missing
but that means having to look that up
no it does not it means pre-computing
that
so for example chemistry data has 200
000 entities if I'm remembering right
and I just checked and maybe this is an
over count but a thousand but almost a
thousand properties okay so that's I
already told you how to do this
engineering no you didn't because I
wasn't in that meeting okay you just
make a bit field how do you populate
that bit field you do the computation
and that's going to take forever
well we do it once
but then they what if there's a fast
patch
we have to deal with that
okay and we're doing it once for the
front end and if so then that's not
gonna coincide with the alpha release
cycle okay which means these are
engineering details which we can
certainly solve we're not going to not
have this feature and have people be
trying to look up things that aren't
there because we couldn't solve the
engineering problem we can solve this
engineering problem
but it's up but it's perfectly
legitimate for properties to have a
missing value and that can even be
informative
of course of course but we don't want
waste time Wasted by people continually
asking for things which aren't there
so I mean you know the case
look
in the case of chemistry for example I
mean that you're taking a corner case
at State countries for example
you know most properties will be there
that you're right that to know that some
property is missing Like A literacy rate
is literacy rate is missing
is worth knowing now maybe with
hierarchical entities
there will be less of an issue but I
don't want to you know notable artworks
of an astronaut
uh we'll just I'm missing all the time
well presumably
um
is is Michael here is anybody who would
like to comment on on hierarchical
client is here I don't think this will
help solving the problem
because I don't think
Jeremy speaks about the ones that come
from a
half type Miss Mitch but from the ones
that are just not there for various
reasons
okay well how many are just not there
for various reasons
it really depends on the entity type and
the probability okay well fine but okay
so we'll do the best we can at giving
this kind of interface and if there's
some case where we can't give this
interface then we won't give this
interface
but when we can give it we will give it
and we're not going to just say because
there's a corner case where we can't
give it we're going to give up on
everything
seems straightforward I'm sorry when you
say this interface you mean whether or
not you're showing a filtered list of
properties or whether or not you're
showing the interface that Noah is
showing at all no no no no
right yeah a filtered list of properties
right you know we don't want gobs of
properties that are all missing
okay
that's absolutely absurd obviously we
don't do this obviously we have a
property that is the list of properties
that are are available
okay
and if there's a further engineering
problem you can come back to me and
we'll try and solve it and if there are
cases where we can't do it they're cases
where we can't do it
okay what's next here
so if you just yeah continue to open the
sections so then the actual search
itself so there are essentially three
searches that you can do here one is a
substring search over common and
canonical property names which is
essentially the default one that's
performed um you can extend that to be a
natural language search
nobody's ever going to figure this out
no open the sections you'll see
so okay so you just start typing in
right
um and uh depending on how fast we can
implement this either this happens
continuously or there's a short pause
but it's basically doing a substring
search on you know the uh the common and
the canonical names of all those
properties
um and it's giving you the filtered list
um you then get that button at the
bottom that says it extends search if
you click on that it'll do it'll
essentially do an alpha search
um and uh and so for example I think
that is actually a real
example there so in other words when you
search pop by just doing you know a
substring search on common and clinical
names it won't find households but if
you go and search Alpha it will return
households in that in that example
um what is it actually doing
uh can someone else chime in
there's an API already
that
um I believe
um I don't have it at the top of my head
you give it the entity type and a
linguistic and it returns all the
properties I think it actually returns
all properties that match that
linguistic but it moves the ones that
match the entity type to the top or
maybe it's just returning maybe it
doesn't know about the entity type and
that filtering is done on the client
actually now that I think about it I
think that's how it works but anyway
um there is an API for getting all the
properties that match a linguistic
the linguistic can be a substring
no
uh
imagine the weight for a mass property
say it again searching for weight when
you mean Mass
so the the the Practical example which
already works and it's worked for a long
time is uh uh create an entity like for
a city or something uh and then uh
control equal
uh in uh you know in the first argument
and type in children and you'll see lots
of hits that are
like children but don't literally have
the word children in it
so you're saying
what are you saying you're saying so so
like yeah okay and uh that's fine now
open square brackets
nope and control equal
children
foreign
you you knew it worked about three weeks
ago because I showed you this three
weeks ago and you thought it was amazing
yeah but and I forgot that it worked and
and and of course it was a feature you
commissioned like like four years ago
and what's that what's that
what the heck is that the short answer
is not the default
um so so that that's what I was saying
where it returns all the properties and
then the client filters and sorts I
understand what it did was clearly wrong
right what it did was clearly wrong it's
given me an autocomplete I said choose
one of the members of the autocomplete
it said that was wrong
that's clearly wrong how did that happen
is that a bug what is going on there
well I I think they're I mean that I'm
aware of there are two possibilities and
someone from the office side should
correct me if there are more but one
possibility is some of those uh entity
properties uh just aren't valid for that
particular entity type and there's been
some discussion around that we kind of I
don't think anyone quite realized that
was an issue and and that that may be
something that that we're on the path to
fix him a little unclear about that uh
so that's issue number one issue number
two so wait a minute that was basically
a bug
uh I would I would classify it as a bug
uh I'm not 100 certain if everyone on
the office side agrees or not well can
we get can we get clarity on that please
who is relevant
I know I I I thought this was
client-side
so so I'm gonna disagree I'm gonna
disagree about Alpha side unless I'm not
remembering all the history
and I've not gone wrong here so how are
we going to fix it what are I think the
missing the missing handshake is that
the all of these will not filtered by
The Entity type that is available for
the entity this is the the step that
hasn't happened before that
that's the front end to do rather than
for Alpha to do that's right because
because the front end doesn't know the
entity type so so the front end is is
supporting all the custom properties to
the top
from looking into boxes
yeah the front end is sorting all the
country ones to the top and what you
were saying is that it should not just
sort them to the top but actually delete
the ones that are not like the average
litter size right
God this is embarrassing
how did that happen
where did we where did the brain
disconnection happen that caused average
litter size to be left here
well okay it's a bug we can fix it I
mean Stephen look that's that kind of
statement is not fair you've you cherry
pick one example that looks crazy and
you have no idea what was actually tried
by the people who developed or tested
this okay and for a feature that you
didn't even remember existed when you
commissioned it
yes well that's a separate problem that
I didn't remember it existed maybe I
tried it three times and it failed three
times for me so I gave up not in my
presence no I I know I know previously
anyway we'll fix this bug
but that
so so that would be one issue is is the
The Entity type just isn't even
appropriate for that particular uh sorry
the NC property isn't appropriate for
the enemy type and then the other issue
is the one that we were talking about
earlier which uh which is that you may
have a valid entity property but it's
missing for this specific entity uh
yes yeah that's a different thing from
from this
well
I mean first thing is to fix this bug
okay so the basic Point you're making
here
oh boy
it's pretty hakalola you know the fact
that these multiple pieces to this and
and how are we ranking the results okay
so so something else to understand about
this interface
uh is that
um
the uh you know think about what you can
do while you're typing Key by key
uh it really doesn't make sense to do a
uh
uh you know to do some kind of more
profound search when you haven't even
necessarily finished typing a word sure
absolutely uh and and and so the what
what Noah is is considering here is you
know can we get some useful stuff Key by
key uh but then can we take advantage of
the more powerful search that we have
and it's a reasonable solution to that
that thing where there's no point in
kicking off the more powerful thing it's
just going to be garbage yeah likely and
I mean there is a question there that
says you know do we even give the option
to perform the natural language search
or is it you know it might be sufficient
just to do I don't know I think it is I
don't think it is I mean unless
I mean it would be nice if we could show
people that they could do the natural
language Thing by typing control equals
in that field
but then I mean
why have you've got two interfaces that
are then kind of trying to do the same
thing
well the place you want to start from
the the intent is for this proposed
interface to just completely replace any
need to do control equal
okay and I don't know how much I don't
think it's going to succeed to succeed I
think there are enough cases where
substring isn't going to cut it
and so okay sorry just to Circle back a
second then you you are not keen on how
this is being handled here with the
extended search button
I mean that is exactly the problem the
extended search button solves yeah no no
I agree and that's a possibility I'm
just saying substring alone is not going
to solve it
but substring with the extended search
possibly is solving it
okay the thing question I was trying to
ask Alan before is what is a good
ordering of these properties because
this ordering is pretty stupid
and do we already have an ordering that
we made for the documentation for each
entity type no we have we have a few
types that I think we've split things
into some subcategories but for
many of them either they're they're too
small to be worth trying to sort
we could we could go back through and we
could do a better ordering
because presumably that's something that
yeah it doesn't especially especially in
this case here where does it mean
alphabetical by what you see which
drives me crazy I mean that's the thing
where when I look at properties when I
see the property list and it's not
alphabetical by what I see it just
starts they're alphabetical by the
canonical name rather than the common
name right which is
you know so okay so we have to have a
curated list here I mean do you do you
do we want to consider having things
that are grouped more kind of property
class well there's no point in group
subsections no no fair enough fair
enough it's not We're not gonna have
that many that they need to
but also they may have yeah I mean
things like countries have hundreds but
we should start off with the very
popular ones maybe we should have the
popular ones at the top then we should
have things grouped in some way
repeating the popular ones
do you see what I'm saying yeah
I mean we really are encouraging people
to use the search here
um and the idea of listing them all
before you've typed anything in
is
uh is if someone wants to explore it and
so if you had them alphabetically
arranged by common name otherwise in
other words by word shown that that
doesn't seem
bad to me no it's not helpless
I agree in some cases there's a small
number but some other cases there are
hundreds
all right let's keep keep looking yeah
it's it's really easy to to get into 500
or more properties and you know the
curation of the you know the sub list
curation aside there's no useful
exploring of the list that size
um
so what I'm pointing out here is that
that as I say that you know this new
interface must not impede what happens
currently you know direct input of a
string argument so if you just know what
you want yeah that's good then yeah it
just it just gets rid of it
I think that was John's idea
um
okay this is just saying I mean this
should be fairly obvious you you know
left and right keys are moving in the
input field uh an up and down arrow keys
are are highlighting you know up and
down in that list
okay
um yeah just including it for
completeness
um okay so attachment points then so
this is you know where we could use this
interface and so there are kind of four
places that we're considering at the
moment so there's the one that we've
seen above which is actually on you know
a typeset entity blob
um
and and this is you know specifically
when you when you open the bracket after
one there's obviously uh uh where it's
not typeset
um there's a there's there's a little uh
bit more to this which is
um you know we'd have to check if the
NCC type is valid uh you know when you
type that open bracket for example there
I put cities right instead of city so we
we wouldn't show anything in that case
um uh and then for the other way around
where you've got the uh where you've got
the type right uh and then the sort of
you know the specific entity is is
either wrong or just for example I put a
hash there uh uh then you know we can't
do the missing filtering obviously uh no
Would we not show anything or would we
still show the The Entity information
subset
oh
um
well it wouldn't work well no no uh but
it could be it could be like a hash or
something or yeah it could be a
programmatic thing exactly uh no good
idea yes yep
um what about are you going to talk
about hovering over the actual entity
what happens if I just hover over the
entity the same as now I would say it's
useful to get the uh uh just
um uh accept that
pick the tick
check it yeah check the check yeah right
there we go now it gives you the input
form which I think is useful but what
about a raft that allows you to ask for
the that allows you to see what
properties there are and allows you to
get the data set
that corresponds to the you know the
data that we know for that entity
uh right so if you scroll up to the very
top quickly
uh there was the
um are you talking about it's like all
the way up right there uh with the
little magnifying glass sorry now sort
of yeah are you talking about that where
you're hovering over there I don't want
the square brackets though I want that
without the square brackets
I want to be able to find properties of
an entity without having square brackets
uh but then in the way of the input form
which I think is the input form is worth
having but we can have both things we
can have a raft that has the input form
and has the ability to find out
properties
I really think it's an important thing
for a discovery of this
okay okay
we can yeah I can mark that up I I I I
don't think that such a thing should be
able to insert code or modify code I I
am not so keen on this one because
because I use entities a lot for
labeling of things and that's definitely
a scenario where I don't want this to
happen
um
sorry entities for labeling
points kinda I wouldn't call out to the
tips I don't want to see the properties
well okay so is there any possibility in
input form we could have this but not an
output form
John that would be a question well yeah
I mean technically yes we're I mean we
already do you know things input versus
output remember if you evaluate uh the
like the France entity there the the
word country disappears on output is is
just like that you know templates we can
change the boxes is no big deal
I see I see okay so we could do that so
we could do a raft on an input but not
output yeah okay this would be better
okay
all right and so then hang on then when
you click on that it's going to insert
both the square brackets and the
template box
yeah but but what I'm suggesting is that
you know such Mouse overs should not uh
go about disturbing the code in place
you know you could you could maybe use
them for inspection put something on the
clipboard maybe stuff like that but uh
but it shouldn't uh you shouldn't be
able to accidentally click somewhere and
and unwittingly corrupt your code
what were we adding to the code like it
auto complete
yeah right but it did the code was maybe
already working and then it blindly adds
a thing which breaks it
but that's true of Auto completion
generals no no no no no in autocomplete
your your carrot is there and you're
typing
so you're clearly editing the code
you're saying not clearly editing the
code
right
you're saying that it should be purely
you know a raft
is purely annotatory yes ever yeah okay
I agree with that
um yeah okay so we can do it after uh
implicit entities as well
um there's a question there that we can
Circle back to
um and oh yeah okay so inside an entity
class filter list in this case
um we would uh only show the the
properties not the entity information
um and this happens when you open the
curly braces of the second argument
there to add the filter
um or uh after you've typed a comma
okay
so there's yeah there's the comma
example
um so I think this is this is probably
not a version one feature but you did
sort of mention it specifically so I
thought I'd just mock something up
um you know some properties can be dated
so for example like you know population
um and so I I think the way we would do
this uh we could either use like a date
setting interface or maybe a natural
language interface I'm not sure the
problem is that we never have we almost
never have things in most properties if
there is a date it is by year and so an
actual date interface that allows you to
set January 7th or something wouldn't be
the right thing
right okay
but it could just but things which are
granular by year it can just bring up a
thing or you type in the year
sure yes I guess so that's that's the
thing that we we would have to kind of
figure out and discuss but the I suppose
just the way of getting to that and
showing that there are dated properties
I suppose that's what I'm showing no I
like that I think that's basically a
good idea
okay
um again I think this perhaps isn't a
version one feature but um
yeah
um okay so I guess we should Circle back
to the questions if you if you open that
section then they linked back into the
text so
um okay what happens on the insertion
point leaves the search field
uh yeah so if you if you if you click on
okay
um so this is just kind of like a quirk
of this which is that um you know the
left and right Keys uh you know if if
you kind of Hit the edge of the field
the input the the insertion point is is
confined to the field but you could get
out of it by hitting backspace which is
going to select the whole thing and then
the idea is that you'd hit it again to
delete it but from that State uh whether
where the whole template box is selected
you could just hit the left or right key
or click away and it's going to leave
that template box there so the question
is
if the insertion points that templates
template box should it just be deleted
entirely and so you just be left with a
pair of empty brackets I would think so
it's a slightly odd case
I would think and and yes that's the
that's the answer that I proposed as
well so I I you and I agree in agreement
Stephen
okay
I think property values we just talked
about that yeah
uh and we talked about his natural
language search even necessary
um well I mean I think we we're saying
yes
yes and this is a good thing to try we
don't know I don't know completely how
it will work well actually okay hang on
because the uh previous version of this
was just doing the natural language uh
search and the idea is that therefore
you really do need the pause and typing
right so you'd you'd type you'd pause
then it would do the natural language
search
um what if we combined both what if we
just did both so you know the pause and
typing uh it would have to be a slightly
larger pause I guess because it's
actually gonna have to go off to Alpha
but it would be combining it would just
be doing both steps at once right so it
would as you type each letter things
would change around and then when you
stop typing things would change again
two seconds later no no no I I think
we'd have to be consistent so so in
other words you'd be typing and nothing
would change as in that that that that
image at the top left there
um as you see that's just the default
list that hasn't been uh will be super
confusing that will be super confusing
by the time that thing is extruded after
your typing it's got to change as you
type
in my opinion just like autocomplete if
autocomplete didn't change until you
finished typing it would be super
confusing
I mean okay okay okay I'm willing to
accept that I I think
I think but um I I I no I think the only
way that that works is if we're willing
to show the the second list
beside the first list and that seems
like it has its own problems
um
for which one
well it is so I mean there's there's the
string sub-match and then there's the
you know what was found by the extended
search
sure
and and and so right now it's you know
basically the string when you clicks
extended search I believe Noah correct
me if I'm wrong that the extended search
results effectively replace the strings
no no no they they they are added to the
top of the list right so for example
households there was just added at the
top the reason that there were added at
the top is because presumably you
already saw the results uh and you
weren't happy with them and then you
decided to do an extended search I think
if we were combining them and doing both
together we'd have to come up with a
better ranking algorithm
um but uh no the idea is that it's
combining you know a search of a
canonical name search over uh um uh
common names and then the language the
natural language search as well into one
list
I think that if it's easy to implement
you should try this I'm not sure what's
going to happen
okay okay because I think it's across
different entities with very different
numbers of properties
Etc I just don't know what's going to
happen
yeah the uh
um
so an another issue with the
asynchronous search is if we if the new
results pop in at the top
then it will replace the thing that is
currently selected
which means you might have kind of a
race condition where the why don't you
put it in the bottom why don't you put
the new things at the bottom like right
where the you know extend search thing
is
I mean if that's being populated
automatically then
um
no we're saying we only populate when
you press extend search oh sorry okay
and then what I would do look I I I I do
like the general idea of you either have
the extend search control or you have
the extent search results exactly
and that that makes it clear that there
is nothing more to do you know that it
was done automatic automatically for you
but so listen I've got two suggestions
first of all I think this missing
section should be closed up by default
and I think
um
additional properties
for this entity type or something
uh
as the label for the button you mean
yeah uh yeah properties missing for this
specific entity
maybe it's a possible thing and then
that opens up and you can get down to
all of those ones that's closed
I actually could say probably is missing
brand and actually give a number of
properties that are missing 17 or
something whatever it is right so you
kind of know if it says
you know one or something or Z well zero
it should put it up there at all
but um you know with some number there
then underneath that it says extend
search you press extend search and it
just
you know produces more properties there
I I would even actually I would even
make a different suggestion but the
missing properties underneath extent
search
so both of them are extruders so missing
properties you open it up and blump it's
got a bunch of properties extend search
you press it and boom it's putting in a
bunch of properties
that's what I'm saying
yes
um I I think I'd have to mock it up to
kind of see so are you envisioning
envisaging that it would get taller the
whole raft or that it would kind of
replace what was there
I don't know I mean I don't know yeah I
was I was thinking about that same issue
and I I would have to think a bit more
about it it's a solution is not obvious
okay but my suggestion is you've got the
initial things at the top
that were gotten by
um the substring search
then you've got the extend search and it
will add more things there
okay probably not very many most of the
time
and then after that you've got these
missing ones which you can open up and
see I think this will work
I would still like to see the missing
Properties by default just to see that
that I've found something even if it's
missing
look if you find nothing
okay if you're finding nothing
non-missing then you could open up that
section
you just don't want a big pile of
missing properties and then the extend
search that has very valid properties
that then are underneath the missing
properties it's just going to look
stupid
you see what I'm saying
yep
so I did just to confirm you're saying
underneath I mean that we do this
yeah go ahead I know but I just want to
make sure you know that it's not it's
it's sort of attached to the bottom it's
not actually in the list right
what is the extend search button okay
then attached to the bottom of missing
properties thing and have that be an
extender too
well so at Noah's concern uh at least
maybe some other things too but at least
about keyboard navigability and uh
that's I I think that I I'm thinking
about that too Noah and I think we just
have to take that off mine and think
about it a bit okay cool
all right I like this this is good now
what about the the uh you need to go in
a second here but what about um
uh
the stuff where we're seeing actual
properties of The Entity
as opposed to just the ability to get
properties
are we are we imagining we're going to
have any kind of card effectively that
represents you know that gives some
summary of The Entity
so that's
I mean first of all
that wasn't kind of in the mission
statement of what we were doing here at
all uh including when we discussed it
initially but but in thinking about you
know the mouse over question we were
talking a bit earlier
um I think that there is some validity
of to the notion of thinking about this
populated amount silver and a bit like
uh what we did uh or you know what was
done in Excel uh with elephant
properties in Excel
um uh that had a card that came up and
you could scroll through and such
um and it didn't have a you know it
wasn't a complete list of properties but
it was a basic list of properties so
they should use the exact stuff I mean
that we created there yeah we also do
have that that shorter list in
information of an entity gives a curated
good well I'd like that I think they'll
be great to have a raft that has some of
that information because you know like
you see London okay well is it London
Ontario at London UK you know what is it
some basic information be very useful
and the information
yeah we already did this so so but I
would suggest that we don't want any of
that in the you know I'm writing code
interface but that would just be
strictly in the in the hover give me
some information interface
what's the difference
oh yeah yeah I mean it would be a rough
type thing yeah yes yes
the essentially that little information
Pane and if there wasn't an open closed
bracket after it uh the little
magnifying glass to to browse the
properties so essentially there'd be
three things in that wrap okay
by the way that flag is too big small
point
Michael would you want these rafts to
come up in output form
I would say no
because if I wanted to do something I
would anyway click in the whole output
cell which would make it an input cell
maybe all right so provisionally not I
would be concerned that we have Legacy
uses of it that if if it did start
coming up in output form we'd have to go
back and and realize a number of things
I kind of agree with you
all right
well good stuff any other questions that
we need to cover right now
um there was one minor thing about if
it's an implicit entity uh it can take
the argument entities
um so we just want to include that in
the uh you know in the in the um entity
information list
like they're there yeah on screen you
just had it you just scroll past it
um
so so here yeah that can actually take
entities
um so presumably we should it just seems
a bit odd to add entities as a query to
an entity and so that's why I wanted to
check should we add it to that that top
list
um
only in certain cases right only in the
case where this is a property class
yeah I I think Noah's just asking you
know the the list of four entity
information properties in this
particular scenario do we make it five
in this case yes yeah yes in a case
where it's a um
um it's an entity class
well it's not an entity class it's just
an implicit entity
um but in that case in the case where it
isn't an explicit entity where saying
entities wouldn't make any sense
yeah yeah okay yeah
is if I take this so there's a mock-up
so I can't do it but but um but I took
that and I said entity list of this
thing I would get a list of entities and
that's what entities is doing the
entities property is doing the same
thing I see okay
um
this looks good this is going to be very
nice this is going to be very useful
um
okay if there's nothing else here we
should wrap it up and thank you very
much okay
okay see you all soon bye